the way to really do stuff is to do the  stuff you actually like to do and  everybody's tricking you along the way  including yourself of all the other  things you need to do when you become  whole and confident enough like this is  just what I do and and this is the real  brain when you're okay with where it  taps you out at when you're like cool  I'm only going to make three hundred  thousand dollars a year when you can get  there or 50 or five million or whatever  it may be when you just can get cool  with where you're at and what you're  good at and what that leads itself to a  couple of funny things happen you start  saving a lot of time on other stuff  which allows you to play the game  slightly different and opens up other  opportunities that you would have never  had